getting [ __ ] ready it's Monday morning
[ __ ] nothing but elbows and
[ __ ] you understand me I don't want
to hear no whining I don't want no
crying the Bluebird of happiness is not
gonna knock on your door your life is
not gonna be where you expect you gotta
go out there and [ __ ] take it you
understand me they're not gonna just
[ __ ] hand it to you and that's what
Mondays are [ __ ] about so
either you're in today oh yeah listen to
this bud you think you're [ __ ] playin
Dyson what I got coming up to there
there you go [ __ ] we got a
little piece of ash we got some reefers
doing everything tonight you understand
so get ready to go grab your [ __ ]
notebook
grab your boss or loop the flagging it
ready a [ __ ] rock here
[Music]
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive God gave me another day the
[ __ ] slain dick don't just sit there
looking at me smoke some reefer write
your notes do your 22 bosoms so [ __ ]
salute the flag and get the [ __ ] out
there and let these [ __ ] know
what you're all about what I had a great
time last week out who gives a [ __ ] what
happened last weekend it's what happens
to damn what you gonna do this week
[ __ ]
last week was last week if you guys came
out to Vegas
last week I love you [ __ ] I had
a great time we got down some good
people showed up but that don't mean
nothing that was last week this is this
week they'll all changed as I've been
here for an hour
[ __ ] Johnny construction don't want to
do nothing I come out here do a
periscope for you now they want to
[ __ ] start choppin that's the story of
my life that I don't give a [ __ ] we keep
moving forward you understand me look at
this look at this to the one-eyed you
were on [ __ ] fire what what's going
on
you think I'm gonna show up with some
[ __ ] Fugazi Reaper ain't got time for
that [ __ ]
you're my family I'm with you you're
with me and he's punk-ass [ __ ] they
want to be with us the other family
we're gonna nap
look at that actually it's all about
Monday morning get motivated off listen
it's 20 and 9 everywhere they had two
[ __ ] meetings I wrote a book
paragraphs words of book and now a
minute to meet the Man of Steel do a
little workout I got a 12 o'clock
I got a 2:30 and I got a 625 today
that's on my Jimmy rolls not to mention
I'm thinking my throw up at school and
take out a wall it's not really school
it's [ __ ] science campus today she's
gonna discover the [ __ ] planets or
some [ __ ] but I love it
and then after that we go for a little
frozen yogurt I show up with my little
grandpa from The Munsters haircut and
that's it you bad [ __ ] again I
want to thank you Utah Salt Lake City is
almost sold out there's a few tickets
left for Thursday night jump my little
[ __ ] I don't want to hear you
crying you know how to Mormons off and
you better show up with that Mormon
reefer that's the [ __ ] I want that's the
[ __ ] that makes seven women wanna suck
the same thing and you imagine that Reid
number two Kansas City
I'm coming in big with Dean Del Ray Joey
what's with the [ __ ] ear beat let's
pop in and smoke some reefer let's smoke
some reefer
nothing like feeling that [ __ ] going
through your [ __ ] mind
opening up different problem and as the
Hindus qualit the chakras as a matter of
fact I was smoking right here from
Sunset herbal a little [ __ ] Hindu
Kush the leftover from last week this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] unbelievable you [ __ ]
smoke this [ __ ] you change your name to
fatality on there anyway
the churches of what's happened now is
ready for you my main man
Joey Alvarado talking about [ __ ] body
weight exercises considering the
kettlebells that type of [ __ ] you gotta
mix it up from time to time it all can't
be haha and he did I just have a little
conversation and Kostya where we are in
our hearts cuz that's the most important
thing nobody ever tells you what's on
their mind me I don't give a [ __ ] what
am i 55 find out much sign left on this
planet I'll tell you what's on my [ __ ]
mind there's a big boy he gives a [ __ ]
understand I'm just a [ __ ] fat sow I'm
trying to put the pieces together
that's good another little piece of head
and this [ __ ] here oh lordy
right there right in the middle check
this out
they right in the middle of all right
there you put that little piece of
hashish hashish I'm mixing the [ __ ]
Egyptians with the Hindus that's a bad
combination but I'm taking that [ __ ]
shot you follow me beside that that's it
and that's that I just wanted to get
together with you tell you the podcast
is up
okay this tool few tickets left for you
Tama Thursday night and to tell you the
most important thing it's Monday mother
[ __ ] they can't take that away from
you they can't take that away from you
get up get out there so lose the flag
tell these [ __ ] you own it you
own it
and listen I got a GB I got selling
these they I look back in the seventh
grade but that's the past is the
[ __ ] future today I'm the king
of the world he said so I said so why I
scratched my ball I sniffed my [ __ ]
fingers and I attack today like I
[ __ ] own it which I do all over at
the end of the day and that's all that
matters that's it and that's that you
guys are expecting some stand-up jokes
I'm dropping knowledge on you
[ __ ] to let you know if I'm a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] more and I can put
two and two together did you imagine
what you [ __ ] savages could do stop
sitting there waiting for something
they're not gonna talk this ain't gonna
give it to you you gotta get up and
[ __ ] take it you follow me
we're like Joey the blood pressure I'm
saying that the heart only got so many
dicks
oh yeah
that's what it's all about
it's Monday either you're in or you're
out you wanna keep complaining or you
wanna do something about it I complain
for years now I do something about it
and that's why we are where we are you
follow me
don't forget July 26 [ __ ] we added
there's a few tickets left for [ __ ]
that Thursday night and warm and bill
they're in Salt Lake City you know I
love you crazy [ __ ] bring the
reefer and Kansas City me and Dean Dell
rizzi this is going to be a week of
[ __ ] rock and roll barbecue and
smoking reefer August 9 2011 at the
improv that said that's that the church
is up let's finish this Baum I don't let
you leave until we finish this boat what
type of host would I be if I didn't let
you finish the [ __ ] hose
like I said man with family I'm with you
you're with me and these punk-ass
[ __ ] want to be with us but no mas
it's just we're a tight-knit group
you follow me we connect through [ __ ]
out Moses
[Applause]
no you [ __ ] are handling that's
why I'm with you listen the Apple don't
fall far from the tea were all meant to
be together you know I'm saying we made
some mistakes but now we're here [ __ ]
them all society don't want us I don't
want that I don't want to be part of
society if it means I have to wait
glasses and other people and do the same
sure everybody else does I'm gonna watch
superhero movies that's not being a man
that's not what it's about to me so I'm
sorry if I don't fit your [ __ ]
demographic beside that it's Monday that
didn't get my Mattel I binged up okay
focus or you know that's not easy my
let's go oh I'm me CK members world
color for entire forget the lowly will
you
cuz I'm telling you [ __ ] so get
out there whatever your dream is attack
it don't let these [ __ ] put you
down look at his face there's no dream
with this place I'm gonna do one thing
with this face put a [ __ ] stocking
over and rob people but no I just [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
I'm dealing my own son to [ __ ] cards
I'm dealing my own 21 you do the same I
love your [ __ ]
stay black don't take no [ __ ] from
nobody and most importantly keep your
eyes open or you won't lay over its
people because you never know
Isis is still there we got to get to
them before they get back remember Uncle
Joe we love you and we got another
podcast dropping Wednesday I'll see you
next Thursday night Utah stay black